HEADLIGHTS BECAUSE JEFF SESSIONS
RECUSED HIMSELF.
IS THERE SOMETHING LAYING IN
WAIT TO TAKE THE SPOTLIGHT OFF
THE PRESIDENT TOMORROW?
REQUEST TO EXAMINE SOME OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S EMAILS DURING
SEVERAL CRUCIAL WEEKS BEFORE THE
2016 ELECTION.
AND FOX NEWS IS WORKING TO
CONFIRM THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
INTERNAL WATCHDOG HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATING WHY A CRITICAL
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION SEEMED TO
STALL ONCE IT REACHED
ANDREW MCCABE.
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT SOURCES
COMPLAINED TO FOX NEWS THAT FBI
HEADQUARTERS APPEARED TO SLOW
ROLL OR REVIEW OF CLINTON EMAILS
FOUND ON THE LAPTOP SHARED BY
ANTHONY WEINER AND HUMA ABEDIN.
THE LINE OF QUESTIONING IS
REPORTEDLY FOCUSED ON WHETHER
McCABE OR ANYONE ELSE AT THE
BUREAU WANTED TO AVOID TAKING
ACTION ON THE NEWLY RECOVERED
LAPTOP EMAILS UNTIL AFTER THE
ELECTION.
AFTER MEETING WITH FBI DIRECTOR
CHRISTOPHER WRAY ON MONDAY ABOUT
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
INVESTIGATION, McCABE WAS
REMOVED AND PLACED ON TERMINAL
LEAVE.
>> Bret: WHERE ARE WE ON THE
RELEASE OF THE INTEL MEMO?
>> THERE IS CONFLICTING REPORTS.
THE CONSENSUS IS SOONER RATHER
REPUBLICAN STAFF MEMO
DOCUMENTING ALLEGED SURVEILLANCE
ABUSES DIVIDED AMONG PARTY
LINES.
>> WE ARE DOING SOMETHING THAT
IS KEEPING US LESS SAFE.
>> AFTER THE REMOVAL OF AND ARE
McCABE, THE SIXTH FBI
HOUSE SPEAKER PUT THE EMPHASIS
ON EURO SENIOR LEADERSHIP.
>> THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
MALFEASANCE AT THE FBI.
>> AFTER MONDAY'S VOTE BEHIND
WHITE HOUSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOLD AIDES HE
WANTS THE MEMO OUT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT NOT BEFORE A STATE
OF THE UNION.
THE COMMITTEE'S SENIOR DEMOCRAT
WARNED OF NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS.
>> THERE WAS A VOTE OF
POLITICIZED THE DECLASSIFICATION
PROCESS OF INTELLIGENCE AND
POTENTIALLY COMPROMISE SOURCES
AND METHODS.
>> A SOURCE TOLD FOX THE MEMO
WAS DRAFTED TO DELIBERATELY
ELIMINATE NATIONAL SECURITY
INFORMATION.
IN A RECENT INTERVIEW, THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN'S
HAD GREAT CARE WAS TAKEN.
>> THERE'S A WAY TO COMMUNICATE
WHAT I THINK WE NEED TO CONNECT
IT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
REVIEWED THE MEMO SUNDAY, TWO
FROM LEGAL, FOLLOWED UP.
SOURCE FAMILIAR SAID THEY COULD
NOT POINT ANY FACTUAL
INACCURACIES.
THE FBI HAD NO COMMENT.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
DISPUTED THE CHARACTERIZATION.
>> DEMOCRATS SEIZED ON THE
LETTER FROM JANUARY 24.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ON FOX THE
TERM "RECKLESS" IS MOOT.